[Music]
it's a real moment
[Music]
[Applause]
I tried my best I just wanted to do the
song justice because it's such a huge
song and such you know like legends have
performed it so yeah I mean given that
all that emotion because it's a huge
song writing and hitting those notes how
did you feel moments after oh my god it
felt so good after I mean first of all I
had to worry about trying to get down
but then after that it felt incredible
because the judges had such amazing
things to say everybody stood up for me
which was just like overwhelming did you
feel like you have something to prove
tonight oh absolutely after last after
at the judge cuts when Simon told me he
thought it was annoying and he did
really think I picked the right song I
thought I had a lot to come out and sort
of prove and I got the go to buzz there
but I still feel like I needed to come
back and really prove myself especially
to him he's the toughest one now I was
telling everyone when I was watching
watching your performance after you were
so calm cool collected employees but be
honest with me when you walked out that
stage you do like yes like I got through
it and they enjoyed it and that's all
you know what do you hope Jennifer
Holliday in Jennifer Hudson have to say
about this performance I hope that they
see it and I hope that they approve this
pamphlet approval would be more than
amazing
[Music]
you